happy Halloween weekend I'm Kat I'm
going to be doing the top 5 news stories
of the week but it's also a costume
contest so please vote with your comment
below who you think won first up we have
day of the dead our first story is
actually kind of a bummer Turtle Rock
announced that they're no longer going
to be working on evolve but in good news
we have Mario you can always count on
Mario evolve developer turtle Rock is
saying goodbye to the game the studio
announced they're no longer going to be
working on the 4v1 monster hunting game
turtle rock founders Chris Ashton and
Phil Raab stated it's always hard to
leave one of our games behind left 4
dead was no different and now it's
evolves turn there will always be a
special place in our hearts for our past
projects no matter what happens with
evolve in the future we'll know it was
born in this studio and developed by
this team alongside this beautiful
community turtle rock does not own the
evolve franchise GTA and Red Dead parent
company take 2 does having paid the ten
point eight nine million to buy the
franchise during th queues bankruptcy
auction turtle rock itself bid on the
franchise but it wasn't enough Ashton
and Rob went on to say this is the life
of a triple a game developer who aren't
self funded and don't own their own IP
we don't make the call
we are happy to have gotten the
opportunity to do something risky
something new and innovative we created
a brand new sci-fi world we got to go to
planet shear and interact with alien
flora and fauna we got to hunt down trap
and kill giant monsters and we got to be
the monster with an awesome experience
even though turtle rock has stopped
development this isn't goodbye
turtle Rock has lots of stuff in the
works and they said the game will still
be available we'll see you all again
another time on another world next up is
the ps4 getting two new controllers that
look eerily similar to Xbox one elite
controllers
oh hey diva nerf this two controllers
from Razer and what I'm going to
pronounce a snake on we're announced
today on Germany's PlayStation Blog the
Razer rage ooh features more than a few
similarities with the elite controller
it's got two extra shoulder buttons and
two rear triggers
trigger option which allows you to more
quickly pull the triggers to maximum
input you can flip between two profiles
it also features a 3.5 millimeter
headset jack with integrated controls
and rubber caps on the analog sticks
that can be removed the net con
revolution pro offers a different take
most notably it flips the position of
the left analog stick and d-pad to
resemble an asymmetric design of an Xbox
controller
it also features four shortcut buttons
an eight-way d-pad which are described
as highly precise analog sticks it can
store up to four profiles for remapping
buttons it also has a 3.5 millimeter
headset jack and internal compartments
for storing weights both controllers are
compatible with all ps4 s and they can
be connected to the system using a
detachable three meter USB cable prices
weren't announced and again these were
announced for those in Germany says
it'll be out by Christmas but no word
yet for the controller for the rest of
us next up I'm here with this Hogwarts
student and this Gothic Lolita to tell
you that Nintendo has said you ain't
seen nothing about the switch just yet
don't act like you're not impressed
Nintendo has more surprises to share
about the console in the future we
haven't shown everything a spokesperson
for Nintendo told The Wall Street
Journal first and added that Nintendo
will announce more details about the
console next year ahead of its release
in March our report earlier this week
stated that Nintendo would announce the
switches price and system specifications
in 2017 we learned on Friday that
Nintendo stock value dropped by 6.5
percent one day after revealing the
console that's a bigger drop than when
Nintendo announced the Wii U in June of
2011 some analysts have doubted the
Nintendo switches ability to appeal to a
wide audience it's still a bit early to
tell though so check back to GameSpot
for more information on the Nintendo
switch as we get it our second biggest
news story of the week is of course
Skyrim special edition with all the news
from out the entire week it's pretty
cool isn't it phew I'm Asian Rick Skyrim
special edition came out today on three
platforms ps4 Xbox one and PC with mod
support there's a lot of mods to choose
from and more coming each day like
adding a new difficulty level removing
health regeneration
and in villages and making named dogs
invincible because dogs should never die
you can check out the full list of mods
on GameSpot currently there's 209
consoles are different though Xbox
currently has the most with 100 and ps4
has 27 Xbox one and ps4 mods are more
limited than PC as the consoles have
storage limits of 5 gigabytes and one
gigabyte respectively more importantly
ps4 mods are restricted to using in-game
assets modders can't create their own
work from scratch or craft scripts that
are often used for complex creations
this limitation is seemingly part of the
deal but says destruct with Sony in
order to allow mods on the platform in
Skyrim and fallout 4 the pc version of
the special edition is free for anyone
who owns the game and it's three DLC
packs and finally in Skyrim news
Bethesda's Pete Hines published a
totally bogus doctor's note that excuses
you from any obligations
now get playing you might have lost that
lovin feelin when it comes to Pokemon go
that's a shame because they just
released a Halloween update
Niantic has launched a new update for
the popular mobile game Pokemon go as
announced on the games website the
update adds new egg patterns and
notification features among other things
specifically the pattern on eggs will
vary depending on the distance required
to hatch them you can see what it looks
like here additionally each pokemons
info screen has been updated to include
Pokemon type icons while the game will
also now alert you to when the Pokemon
go Plus battery gets low
lastly the update also adds minor text
fixes though Niantic did not provide any
specifics on what changed Niantic
announced the game's first ever in-game
event for Halloween as part of the event
spooky pokémon like ghastly and Haunter
will show it more often additionally
you'll have the opportunity to earn
extra Pokemon candy for everything you
want to know about Pokemon go and their
Halloween event you're gonna want to go
back to GameSpot so there you have it
our top 5 news stories of the week and
finally we end on David's pumpkins be
sure to leave your comment below so we
know who won this costume contest happy
Halloween
[Music]
[Music]
in the class released